我们再来看看规定里说礼金不属于彩礼。
第一呢，
一方在生日、
节日这些有特殊纪念意义的时候给的价值不大的礼物，
礼金可不算作彩礼，
重点是有纪念意义的时间节点和价值不大。
像开头说的1314520，
生日、
七夕、
情人节这些时候给的金额不大的，
就不属于彩礼的范围。
第二呢，
是一方为了表达或者增进感情的日常消费性支出，
也不算做彩礼，
比如一起吃饭、
旅行、
坐飞机、
开房、
住宿啥的。
第三，
其他价值不大的财物算是一个兜底条款，
下去买个口红、
香水、
面霜、
衣服、
裤子、
鞋子等，
这些价值不大的财物都不能认定为彩礼。
然后我们再看第4条规定，
婚约财产纠纷里，
婚约一方和实际给付彩礼的父母可以当共同原告，
婚约另一方和实际接收彩礼的父母可以当共同被告，
最高人民法院其实在2017年8月26日还有一个关于审理彩礼纠纷案件中能否将对方当事人的父母列为共同被告的答复，
这里面的范围其实更大。
不光是可以把接收彩礼的对。
对方父母一起告，
那么接收彩礼的对方亲属都有可能成为案件的共同被告，
这么一推导呢，
婚姻财产纠纷的被告可能是女方，
女方父母，
甚至是女方的亲属，
但是在离婚纠纷里面，
一方提出返还彩礼的诉讼请求，
当事人只能是夫妻俩，
可不能把别人拉进这个离婚诉讼里面来，
这个是比较专业的一个点啊。
我们再来看第5条规定，
双方已经办理结婚登记且共同生活，
离婚时一方请求返还，
按照习俗给付彩礼的，
人民法院一般不予支持。
但是如果共同生活的时间较短，
且彩礼数额过高的，
人民法院可以根据彩礼实际使用情况及价妆情况，
综合考虑彩礼数额、
共同生活以及运律情况、
双方的过错等事实，
结合当地的习俗，
确定是否返还以及返还的具体比例。
翻译过来就是说，
如果双方领了证也住一块儿了，
离婚的时候男的还要求退彩礼，
一般法院就判不退了，
但是呢，
如果共同生活的时间短，
且彩礼数额还特别高，
那么法院就可以根据彩礼花到哪里去呢，
有没有嫁妆，
嫁。
发到哪里去了？
综合来考虑彩礼的数额，
你们共同生活的时间有多长呢？
有没有孕育子女？
如合是谁的过错呀？
再结合当地的习俗来确定是否返还以及返还多少。
那么多少钱算是彩礼过高呢？
法院认定彩礼数额是不是过高，
得综合考虑彩礼给诉方所在的地区人均可支配收入、
警方的家庭经济情况以及当地的习俗等因素。
注意啊，
他考虑的不是接收方的经济条件，
考虑的是给付这方所在地的居民人均可支配收入，
付方的家庭经济状况以及当地的习俗。
比如说广东吧，
彩礼要求一般都不算高，
要是领了证还一起生活了，
那想要退那两三万的彩礼基本不可能。
但是像江西某些地方，
他的彩礼数额真的很高，
像288000、
388000、
488000、
588000、
688000都大有人在。
这种彩礼数额特别高的，
结婚时间又短了，
红军的时间也短了，
那法院就得考虑好多因素来确定是不是返还，
以及返还多少。
比如说彩礼花到哪里去了，
女方有没有给陪嫁，
陪嫁的嫁妆用到哪里去了，
彩礼的数额具体是多少，
共同生活了？
几个月、
几年，
有没有怀过孕，
有没有流过产，
有没有生过孩子，
过错在谁，
有没有家庭暴力，
有没有一些恶习，
有没有出轨、
嫖娼等等，
这些情况还要考虑当地的习俗，
我了解的情况是，
现在的审判时间当中，
一般只要生了小孩儿，
就算结婚的时间短，
共同生活的时间短，
彩礼只要不是高的离谱，
通常法院也不会要求退彩礼，
要是女方怀孕或者流产，
就算退也只是象征性的退点，
毕竟女方在怀孕、
生产或者流产生育的过程当中遭受不少罪，
在经济上对女方有一点倾斜也是公平的。
第6条规定呢，
是双方没有领证，
但是一起生活了，
如果一方要求返还彩礼，
法院也是根据刚才那些因素，
像彩礼的具体金额呀，
实际用途呀，
嫁妆有没有呀，
嫁妆用到哪里去了呀，
共同生活的时间呀，
命运子女的情况呀，
双方是有过错呀，
当地的习俗呀等，
来确定是不是要返还以及返还多少，
咱们把这个规定算是捋完了。
那么彩礼到底该不该要，
该要多少？
该什么时间节点要？
要到的彩礼该怎么安排？
彩礼的所有权该归谁，
是不是？
归女方的父母，
还是女方自己，
还是归小两口一起共同所有，
作为生活的启动资金，
这些问题在法律上没有明确的规定，
但是有一点是明确的，
法律从来没有禁止过要彩礼这个行为，
法律也不鼓励靠彩礼发家致富，
靠天下彩礼去搅黄年轻人的婚姻。
对于彩礼的问题，
确实是一个复杂而又现实的议题，
不同的地区，
不同的家庭背景以及不同的个人观念，
都会对彩礼有着不同的看法和处理方式。
如果你是收入很高，
能力很强，
自己独立性更强，
父母也可以给你托底的女性，
且你本人认为要彩礼这件事情很俗气，
那么龙菲姐表示尊重。
这样的女性往往是经济上有着足够的保障，
他们凭借自己的能力和努力，
能够为自己创造良好的生活条件。
他们可能更注重感情的纯粹性，
不希望财力成为婚姻的一种负担。
他们有足够的底气去追求自己认为真正重要的东西，
而不会被传统的观念所束缚。
他们在婚姻中更看重的是双方的平等、
尊重和共同成长，
他们相信通过自己和伴侣的努力，
可以共同创造美好的未来。
然而，
如果你本人是属于农村女孩。
或者收入不高，
能力一般，
娘家也靠不住，
那王菲姐劝你大大方方在领证之前要一笔彩礼，
数额不要太高，
单独存在一张卡里，
这笔钱或许是你将来怀孕、
生产、
哺乳期间的一笔保命钱。
在这些特殊的时期，
女性往往面临着身体和心理上的巨大压力，
同时也可能因为没有办法工作而失去经济来源。
彩礼可以在这个时候为你提供一定的经济保障，
让你能够安心的度过这些艰难的时刻。
感情这个东西谁也说不准，
但是钱真的能在你人生最脆弱的时候，
让你有离开火坑，
好好活下去的底气。
因为在现实生活中，
我们无法预测未来会发生什么，
婚姻可能面临各种各样的挑战和困难，
而经济上的独立和保障，
可以让女性在面对这些问题的时候更加从容和自信，
彩礼不仅仅是一笔钱，
这是一种对自己未来的担保和保障，
同时对于彩礼的安排也要谨慎考虑，
如果彩礼归女方父母所有，
可能会引发一些家庭矛盾，
而如果为小两口共同所有，
作为生活的启动资金，
也需要双方共同去协商和管理，
确保这笔钱能用在刀刃上，
女方自己保管财礼也是一种常见的方式。
那需要注。
第二，
要合理的使用这笔钱，
不要轻易的被他人挪用或者挥霍，
要有勇气拒绝国家或者娘家想要挪用彩礼钱的各种理由和要求。
总之，
彩礼问题根据个人的情况和家庭背景进行综合去考虑。
无论你选择要还是不要彩礼，
都要明确的知道自己的需求和底线。
如果自己选择不要彩礼，
将来就不要拿这个事情强调自己的委屈，
如果自己选择要彩礼，
就一定要内心自洽，
不要觉得不好意思，
别害怕对方会觉得你现实物质，
大大方方为自己未来生儿育女过好每一天做好充分的准备，
恰恰是一个女人成熟理性的表现。
不怕对方觉得自己有经济要求，
坦诚自己对稳定经济生活的渴望并不可耻。